so on its way out of afghanistan the
bide administration left behind an awful
lot of americans but also nearly 90
billion dollars in military equipment
how much is that well only two countries
on the planet have a military budget
larger china and the united states so
the taliban now have the best equipped
military of its size in the history of
the world
what do they have well according to a
tally by the times of london the taliban
just received more than 22 000 humvees
more than 50 000 trucks and other
armored vehicles as well as a sizable
air force
it comes with four c-130 transport
planes dozens of other fixed wing
aircraft and up to 350 combat
helicopters the taliban now has more
black hawks than many developed nations
and those are just the vehicles
taliban soldiers also got more than 350
000 american rifles 126 000 handguns and
approximately 64 000 heavy machine guns
it's quite an arsenal it's all at your
expense
it's a disaster obviously but it also
makes for a striking contrast with what
is happening in this country at the very
moment the white house is arming our new
friends the taliban they are working
hard to disarm you
whether or not it makes the news it is
happening the administration just
announced quietly it is banning some of
the most commonly purchased ammunition
in the united states this move will
certainly and intentionally lead to
severe shortages in this country that's
why they did it
joe biden himself has said repeatedly he
would like to prevent you from owning
the firearms that most americans use to
defend themselves and their families and
those efforts are now accelerating
so how about this as an answer no
you're not allowed to give more than
half a million guns to the taliban guns
that we paid for and then try and take
our guns away in this country sorry
that's not how it works so shut up and
back off now one more word about gun
control from these people until they get
back every single rifle from kandahar
that is the rule
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else